Speaker 1: Let's go next to Eduardo from Brooklyn,
Brooklyn.
Is that Brooklyn, New York?
Of course.
Speaker 2: It is Brooklyn, New York,
Speaker 1: Brooklyn Center, Minneapolis, for
example, Minnesota, rather.
Speaker 2: Well, yeah, I hope not.
I, I think I'm in the best part of New York,
I believe.
Speaker 1: Beautiful.
All right.
What's on your mind today?
Speaker 2: I just wanted to run something
by you, if you don't mind.
Something I've been thinking about.
I've been following a lot of the, you know,
the people recounting the votes and everything.
And obviously nobody's found anything incriminating
or whatever.
But do you think that maybe they're just looking
for just a tiny little spark that would just,
like, justify everything they're doing?
Yes, they do find just like one irregularity,
you will just be like a blitzkrieg of of.
Attacks on everything.
Speaker 1: Yeah, what?
And here's the problem, even if they find
nothing, they'll just say the fraud was hidden
well enough so that we haven't yet uncovered
it and we need to keep going.
So I would even go further than you.
If they find anything at all, then of course,
they will say we need to redo every election
in every state.
There's no question about that.
But even if they find nothing, they will say
we have reason to believe that there is still
something to uncover.
We need more time.
We need more money.
We need more ballots to review.
They don't care.
And this is the problem with conspiratorial
thinking.
If you find evidence, it's evidence of the
conspiracy.
If you find no evidence, the evidence has
been covered up and it's evidence of the conspiracy.
Every either way, they think the conspiracy
is real.
Speaker 2: It's the true definition of a catch
22 is exactly, exactly, yeah,
Speaker 1: Edwardo, I have to ask you, you
have the slightest accent.
Where is that from?
I love it.
Speaker 2: Well, I'm originally from Rio and
Brazil are, but I grew up in the UK, in London,
and I moved to New York about 10 years ago.
Speaker 1: That's interesting.
There's the slightest British hint to your
accent.
It's a it's really a perfect accent, I would
say.
Speaker 2: Well, that's where I learned English,
actually.
Yeah.
Do you mind if I ask you another question?
No, please.
Which comes from my girlfriend, because we
watch your show together and she is fascinated
by you know, we both are fascinated by languages.
And you always you always have like a very
erudite take on sort of world global views.
Oh, and another but she she wanted to ask
you she can be here, unfortunately, right
now.
But she wanted to ask you if you think that
there is a the way that the situation that
people see in the U.S., obviously, the US
is a proponent of a lot of like things that
happen around the world.
But do you think how other news translate
the little nuances of what's happening in
the US in a way that sort of does it justice?
Or do you think that it's like they sort of
put it in their own perspective in it?
This is a great question.
Speaker 1: You know, I can only speak to this
in terms of Argentina because I watch a lot
of Argentinean news because I was born in
Argentina and I see how they cover things
in the United States.
Speaker 2: It I don't see them in Brazil,
Speaker 1: I would imagine.
So I can't say that the I can't say that the
coverage I see of the U.S. and Argentina is
dishonest or inaccurate, but it definitely
lacks context.
So if your only exposure to what's happening
in the U.S. is Argentinean news reporting
about the U.S., I think you definitely don't
really understand what's going on because
it lacks context and it may be unreasonable
to expect.
I mean, listen, when we get American news
about France, it lacks context.
There's no there's no doubt about it.
It's not unique.
But no, I think that a lot of people, if they
mostly get their American news from local
foreign media, they probably don't fully understand
the context in which things are happening
here.
Speaker 2: But do you think that's in the
grand scheme, do you think that that basically
is detrimental to the world of your America?
Do you think that's true?
It makes it a little lighter for them to digest.
Speaker 1: I think if on balance, it propped
the coverage of the US globally, probably
makes people's opinion of the US worse, not
better.
That would be my guess.
Speaker 2: Yeah, I'm with you.
Yeah.
Thanks, David.
All right.
My friend Murray time.
But I take
Speaker 1: care.
Appreciate the call.
Thank you.
Really, really great phone call.